et si l'ordinateur était un bel
objet quelque chose que vous vouliez regarder
et avoir chez vous et si
au lieu d'être entre de bonnes mains,
il était entre les mains de tout le monde, nous
parlerions du changement le plus tectonique
du statu quo  jamais je vous supplie de
gérer les attentes si je vous ai déjà laissé
tomber à chaque [ __ ] de fois, alors je
fais votre action Apple vaut 441 millions de
dollars et votre fille et sa mère
bénéficient de l'aide sociale, elle n'est pas ma fille, vous
devez pouvoir  vois qu'elle
te ressemble on saura bien assez tôt si tu étais
Léonard de Vinci ou si tu penses que
tu l'es tu es le seul à voir le monde de la
même manière que moi personne ne voit le monde de la
même façon que tout le monde attend
le mag qu'est-ce que les gens vont en
faire c'est un résumé tu vas faire que
tu donnes des
instructions contradictoires tu es insoumis rendre les
gens misérables le conseil le moins
tu n'es plus nécessaire à cette
entreprise je me suis assis dans le garage  et a inventé
le f  futur parce que les artistes dirigent et
accèdent à main levée ce que vous faites
n'est pas censé être la meilleure partie de
vous quand vous êtes un père c'est ce qui est
censé être la meilleure partie de vous Je suis
le seul à savoir que ça  le gars est
quelqu'un que vous avez
inventé y a-t-il un plan le plan se
scellera à vous lorsque vous serez prêt à le
voir revenir une super tempête
la guerre et c'est
toi